angers un accident de moto le 30 juin
2013 en allant travailler un dimanche
matin il était 9h et j'arrive à
l'intersection gta même par le kilomètre
du travail je vais pour dépasser une
voiture au moment où je démarre cette
personne là pour aucune raison et
redémarre aussi entre on est en fait
elle vient juste mais fleuret mais pas
assez pour faire tomber mais juste ce
qu'il faut pour le dégel ma trajectoire
et du coup ça m'a sam a dévié vers
l'inter plein central et après je me
souviendrai
quand le médecin est de vous voir et qui
vous annonce que vous êtes paraplégique
avant de comprendre ce que ça veut dire
paraplégique vous faut bien trois jours
donc voilà c'est quand même assez
compliqué c'est surtout le réveil qui
est difficile parce que non c'est parce
qu'on a et notre famille il voit tout
l'extérieur ils ont ça fera plus que
nous la route les faisait tous les jours
tous les jours tous les jours trophée
georges que la connaissez par coeur
c'est pas parce que nous ont conduit
bien que les autres conduisent bien
c'est surtout ça le problème et je veux
dire à tous ceux qui sont pas bien
réveillé qu'ici on trouve mieux de
rester chez eux parce que ils ont
peut-être pas se faire du mal à eux mais
bon peut-être dû faire du mal à d'autres
gens à toute une famille et c'est vrai
c'est vraiment dommage parce comment la
personne qui m'a renversé
j'ai l'intimé conviction qu'elle est au
téléphone je sais même pas s'il a vu ce
qui s'est passé je pense mais voilà quoi
c'est dommage pour pas grand chose quoi